[Music]
I'm with my brother from Turkestan
cookies curry Stan also Turkestan ago
notice Turkistan bolo Muslim some people
might be wondering why they keep saying
the finger this one finger pointing up
it signifies the monotheism of the one
guy this is what Muslims are conscious
of should be at all times and this is
the main message of Islam the call for
the human being to direct all their
worship belts in the gratitude their
thanks there praise to the one and only
creator of the heavens in the earth now
in Arabic we say Allah this is God
Almighty but whenever you see the finger
pointing up
we don't do justice chest pumps we do
everything to keep it humble and to
point to the one up above the one who
created creation the one guy so now you
know with that one stance for one
you were model field but they slump but
now that I was learning promoted peace
mercy Dundee was Joseph its unleash love
about it up it's my so it's my
responsibility now miss Miller
hamdulillah wa salatu was-salam ala
allah sallallahu alayhi wa sallam you
know everything around this has a
purpose the glass has a purpose and one
beyond Jewish the pen has a purpose
the keys in our pocket our purpose I was
thinking like this the nose on my face
has a birthmark
my eyes have a purpose is it I mean you
guys understand the logic how I'm going
mom come on this one was damn with you
but what about me what's my purpose make
it be neurology now the Gracie's
bracelet they said come on ya little if
we give you money if you can beat us
part of it babies do it
listen is do hurting son mother they had
a Gracie challenge Gracie challenged me
because it so it wasn't just talking
theory it was action I thought the
Cornish mark Authority Nagar tricked and
am did you help to put it so that's what
the kind of person I was on the
bookkeeping something I want to prove
evidence help we cannot be starving you
so then I tried it and I was addicted
connecting jiu-jitsu with Islam it's
really lifted me is that Islam also
challenges the human being is lambda I
know I need a lot oldest in the FL area
to the Quran do they not consider the
quran' with care
you had the quran cutting domestic if it
had been from other than allah allah but
human you would find in a many
contradictions this crazy kid issues so
i started to see the man-made religions
yes i'm you have to get a girl you can
see from the face of it [ __ ] them the
great video from it doesn't make sense
it calls you to worship the creation
here at lunch a little dear but what is
unique about Islam Islam buddy second
husband she was the pure monotheism the
tawheed
[Music]
and it was evidence-based wasn't just
blind
[Music]
good question
you see everybody if we understand that
everybody in one point of their life
they have to not because their parents
make a decision for them
we know that the profits awesome that
every child is born on the fitrah I have
told you the hack is from a look at
Yanni I had to do everything up to be 10
gr did you yeah where did you know we
said so we know the ha d for the prophet
saw some every every child is born on on
the pure fitrah as a Muslim yeah his
parents make him a Jew or create their
everybody apart but now as human being I
have to myself I had to make the
conscious decision I've been kissing be
willing to be touching at mom because
Muslim means one who has submitted his
or her will to Allah Allah doesn't
estimate thank you but technically yes
my parents were mr. Monty do young but
growing up in in the home we didn't
really have practice especially music
today debuted camera side yeah until
later today so we really weren't praying
doing fasting we weren't close Muslim so
you know so we know that Islam is an
action right it's a verb it's done B she
loses someone can say oh I train I'm a
jujitsu fighter okay show me so that's
yeah so yeah technically by by by name I
was Muslim but wasn't practicing
I wasn't fulfilling any of the pillars
that might she there's a big saying in
Islam
you know myself if you don't if you
don't live like you believe yes you will
believe like you live yeah I was like
most youth who get exposed to all of the
toxic spiritual toxic things they were
out there in the dunya
gain Scooby Doo and the things that most
of us want you want money you want to
have all the finer things in life
materialism and I experienced the
majority of things that people
experienced but there was something
missing in my life I wasn't contempt I
wasn't happy there was a void oh oh my
god Oh Ames performs among because we
can spend all day talking about job if
we talk in a legal system in Islam maybe
you get maybe you get them to agree on
one thing
we should have come the I'm not sure but
now you have another problem on another
problems because they seeing things from
a different perspective or so much then
so now we address it topic but we bring
them back to the OMG one is that we talk
about the oneness of Allah along billion
computers that the messengership
actually lost in the met and then the
guidance the Quran Quran we talk about
the Hereafter try to educate them on the
legislature and who Allah is Allah al
aliy 18 and then they will start to
understand the legislation announcer oh
yes yes opportunity
on the Mae West ruler you even have
stories where a young girl games because
she's Muslim and then she goes to the
University in her last year and she's
always being invited to come to the
party come to the party and she's
resisting she's resisting finally in the
last year
she goes she's okay my last year she
gives in and she goes in there but she
doesn't drink the alcohol she's drinking
kool-aid
cooley like jul 8 what she's in the
wrong environment men and women make
seen dancing party you know so they put
the Mickey in her drink and she ends up
getting raped she gets pregnant
Tommy nikolia and now she ends up
committing suicide right so these are
those small steps of Shaitaan that now
when we follow a whole world of
destruction and open but we see that
Allah loves us he's Allah dude whatever
he told us to do up did he it goes back
to it's good for us fasting for instance
a big one why do you Muslims fast
we know it's because Allah said so but
now we see the wisdom and now in America
they're coming with new research that
fasting is potentially a cure for cancer
and many other health benefits
so you have some of the leading
nutritionists help assure that if they
advocated intermittent fasting so we say
look before all of this Allah gave us
this given time and we can go on with
the prayer you have some of the Tony
Robbins of the world the
multi-billionaires
in their books they write definitely as
the top letter the importance of
meditation 20 minutes a days and to
think to reflect
you can even test on your father
literally I do not know this is their
Salah but we have five times a day
scribe for us not that Allah doesn't
need it
but this is our medicine i recharge for
our heart so what I found in everything
in Islam is Santa Fe is for our benefit
is in Allah don't need none of this from
us and when we implement it we benefit
from our sellers techne